poire un spectaculaire rebondissement
dans la sphère du sang contaminé
aujourd'hui la cour de cassation devait
dire si cette affaire relevait d'une
cour d'assises ou d'un tribunal
correctionnel en d'autres termes s'il y
avait là crimes ou délits et la surprise
est venue de l'avocat général qui a
rejoint la thèse des parties civiles en
estimant que lé docteur garetta yalin
aurait dû être jugé par une cour
d'assises pour empoisonnement dominique
verdeilhan
la liste des victimes la liste aussi des
plaignants qui depuis des années
demandent que leur dossier aille devant
les assises dans la salle quelques unes
sont là pour ce dernier combat juridique
et dans l'après-midi une surprise
l'avocat général jean perfetti se range
à leurs côtés ils prônent
l'empoisonnement il évoque une
correctionnalisation douteuses et
demande pour le respect de l'ordre
public le renvoi devant une cour
d'assises des docteur garetta et alain
c'est un travail très long un combat
très long et je crois qu'on est entendu
que la qualification d'empoisonnement
n'était pas une qualification qui
étaient jetés comme ça en l'air c'est
une qualification qui juridiquement à
des bases et qui est maintenant défendu
par la cour de cassation dans cette
affaire le parquet n'a jamais diligenter
une enquête
on la demande depuis neuf ans alors on a
toujours eu l'impression
qu'ils avaient un blocage sur cette
affaire peut-être que
qu'elle était trop près des politiques
assurément pour les victimes c'est ce
soir une victoire mais il leur faudra
attendre mercredi prochain après midi
date à laquelle la cour de cassation
rendra son arrêt en dépend le sort
judiciaire des docteur garetta et alain
mais cet arrêt aura également une
conséquence sur la suite à donner à 25
plaintes 25 plainte pour empoisonnement
actuellement instruites par la justice
et visant les trois anciens ministres et
les membres de leurs cabinets mercredi
prochain la justice pourrait donc
relancer la faire neuf ans après les
faits